we all feel that rejection kills dreams
we all feel that failure kills dreams we
all feel that people kill dreams but
actually there's four words that we say
in our heads to ourselves that genuinely
have destroyed more dreams than all of
those things put together those four
words are what will people say what will
people say how many times have you
stopped yourself from doing something
because you're scared of how people will
react how many times out of the fear of
someone else's opinion or criticism have
you stopped yourself from doing what you
believe in how many times has someone's
perception or perspective stopped you
from living your potential no matter
what you choose to do there will always
be people who find a fault with it there
will always be people who criticize
complain who try to bring you down and
tell you that what you're doing isn't
right it's crazy that we give up what we
most want in life just make based on
people's opinions and the crazy thing is
if we're living for other people's
opinions we'll never be right there'll
always be someone with something that
they won't agree with and this is why
it's so important that we work with our
own conviction we work on what matters
to us it was Aristotle who told us that
there were only three ways to avoid
criticism do nothing say nothing be
nothing and I'm sure none of us want
that of our future so don't let anyone's
opinion stop you don't let anyone's
criticism hold you back keep following
your passions invest in what you believe
in and remember don't let people's
compliments get to your head and don't
let their criticism get to your heart
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
you are probably the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Jay Shetty and my take on his
top 10 a success enjoy
rule number two don't hold back real
empathy
is connecting to someone in their
emotional language not yours
right that's real empathy that's real
connection that's real compassion is
that you're able to communicate with
someone and express your thoughts
in their emotional language not yours
and this is something we struggle with
because when we're feeling tired
exhausted stressed overworked we
communicate more in our language because
we want to be heard not realizing that
when we fight for being heard we
actually alienate the other person
they're just disconnected because we're
speaking a foreign language that's
literally what it sounds like
if this group
is talking to this group and they're
only talking about goals and schedules
and plans
this group is going to say but what
about the people
what about people are exhausted people
are tired what about how they feel that
doesn't mean they don't agree with you
they just want you to take into account
people
it's not that they don't agree with your
plans and goals and schedules and any of
that
and you may sit there and go well they
don't understand they just don't get it
like we need to hit these targets they
don't understand
but you're both on the same team
you both need each other both mindsets
are important so then the question
becomes
how do we care about people in the
pursuit of our goal
and that's where all the focus goes the
focus Now isn't well we're right because
we're going to hit targets and that's
what pays for everything or no we're
right because we care about people and
obviously people are everything it
becomes well how do we hit our targets
and care for people how do we do that if
we both start having that conversation
you get some incredible Synergy so much
of our life and society and our being
today is divided we have work and life
we have family and friends we have
personal and professional and so many of
our challenges in life come from the
fact that we think we have to be in two
places at once that we have two sets of
responsibilities
and when we talk about our well-being we
often think that's what we do after work
that's what we deal with when we get
home that's what we try and do on the
weekend
and then when we're at work we're
wondering whether our well-being is in
the right place
I've sat down and interviewed some
incredible individuals uh Jocko willink
being one of them
and when I've sat down with these Navy
Seals I've talked to them so much about
the power of breath the power of
presence the power of Stillness we often
think that force is the most powerful
thing in the world
and sometimes when you speak to the
strongest people in the world they'll
say it's not force it's Stillness
right Stillness is the most powerful
thing in the world Stillness creates
more Force than Force itself because
that Stillness creates Clarity it
creates Focus
so think about how you can find again
just two three minutes for that all of
these habits that I'm sharing today
should take you no longer than five
minutes each
and then finally e t i m e e is for
exercise moving sweating uh one of my
favorite things is to see families
compete over ten thousand steps you'll
be shocked at how much your partner is
competitive when you all put on a Fitbit
or a wearable or whatever it may be and
see who gets the ten thousand steps
first the idea of moving is so powerful
for our mind and our psychology
[Music]
so those are four habits exercise
probably a bit longer than five minutes
but the rest of them if we could add
thankfulness
inspiration
meditation and exercise to our daily
weekly habits
you'll find that your personal
well-being your personal connection with
yourself
will Elevate to levels that you never
could have imagined
these simple habits have a giant impact
these simple daily Investments have
giant Rewards
and they take very little time
they take very very little time
and it's also a beautiful thing to bring
to the table to practice with your
children to practice with your partner
it's something that
can be nicely brought into a family
activity that makes it easier for each
and every individual
so that's the first thing the first
thing is you if your foundation is
just if you're feeling rooted and
grounded everything else is possible
from that place rule number three invest
in your passion I was 15 I really needed
the job I'll even tell you what it was
I'll confess I was applying to a local
supermarket and I wrote down that I
really really really wanted to work
there
that was my life there you go and I've
got nothing against supermarkets they're
awesome I actually really enjoyed the
experience afterwards and I'm glad I did
it how many of you have ever lied on a
resume or a CV tell me right now in the
comments and don't lie now I'm guessing
most of you wrote down no well that
means that 57 of you are lying because
that's how many of us embellish our
skill set on our resumes
55 of us lie about our responsibilities
it's when all you did was get Starbucks
and coffee and you say that you were the
team performance manager or maybe all
you did was filing and copying and you
said you were the big project manager on
the job I do everything around here okay
42 of people lie about the dates they
worked it's when you work somewhere for
three days but you wrote three months
easy mistake oh UPS 26 of people even
lie about the company they work for I
work for the CIA they interview 2000 HR
professionals and asked them what were
the most memorable resume lies I'm gonna
tell you them right now let's see if you
can see yourself in some of them
applicants claim to be the assistant to
the prime minister of a country that
doesn't have a prime minister applicant
claimed to have an Olympic gold medal
applicant claimed to have 25 years of
experience at age 32 32 minus 25 yeah
seven you started working when you were
seven applicant applied for the same
position twice with different work
histories now I don't know who's going
to fall for that but it's a pretty
creative idea I'd give them the job just
based on that so I started digging a bit
deeper I was looking at all these
statistics and wondering and asking
myself why do we lie why is it that over
half of the people in the world lie on
their resumes to get these jobs to get
these positions we need the money that's
true we need to work that's true but
there was something at the root cause of
it and I want to talk to you about today
one of the biggest reasons is because
there are so many job specifications and
requirements out there now that are
stopping us from feeling confident but
the root cause is self-awareness When We
Were Young we had Hobbies we had
passions we had skills that we could
articulate that we could share with
people but as we've grown older we've
forgotten about them we struggle to
express our passion for absolutely
anything the more self-aware we become
the more confident we become about the
skills that we have we're so busy trying
to convince people that we have skills
that we don't even care about that we
forget the ones that we really already
have see the truth is that everyone has
potential and talent but we've been made
to believe that we need to have a
certain checklist to give us a certain
status when reality is a lot of the
people who are doing what they love
would never get a job and a place out
there we've been made to believe that
there are certain skills and
qualifications that Define us but I'm
going to ask you to answer this question
first what do you love and what are you
good at figure that out what do you love
and what are you good at and invest in
that see people say follow your passions
I say you can follow them but make sure
you work on them make sure you invest in
them make sure you improve on them
because as you get better as you grow in
what you love and what you're good at
that's going to become the most powerful
asset you have so next time you think
you're lying on a resume to get a job
think about whether that's a job you
really want rule number four do not seek
revenge I'm sure you've heard the phrase
before success is the best revenge in my
opinion the best revenge is no Revenge
at all what why revenge in Latin was
often referred to as vindictor or
injuria and today the dictionary
definition shows Revenge to being
resentful or vindictive Spirit now I
don't know about you but when I hear
about words like this Zen vindictive
injury what I find is that you can't fix
yourself by breaking someone else that's
a good point it's so true that sometimes
people cause us the greatest pain mean
the greatest suffering the greatest
betrayal the greatest lack of trust
miscommunication and almost destroy our
insides but when that happens you have a
choice to move forward or to destroy
yourself further see when you think that
success is the best revenge or you want
to take any revenge in any form at all
it's like holding a hot piece of coal
wanting to throw it at someone else in
the process of picking up that hot piece
of coal we burn our own Palm we burn our
own hand even if we get to the point of
chucking it at the person we've already
caused ourselves more pain more strain
and more pressure simply by picking up
the baggage of wanting to get our own
back on someone or wanting to take out
that pain and pressure on another
individual we're now carrying that pain
and pressure ourselves and I know it's
easier said than done I know that it's
difficult but if someone has caused you
pain don't allow them to win by doing it
to yourself again
remember the person that broke you is
not going to be the person that fix you
healing is totally up to you and that's
why the best revenge is no Revenge at
all also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five learn how to
think most of us have been to school
most of us may have been to college or
university but most of us will feel that
our education let us down our education
didn't give us the skill feels the
abilities the mindset that help us
thrive in life
and most of all our education did not
prepare us for our real future real
decisions real relationships that's why
so many of us feel lost confused and
bewildered as we get older in life from
20 to 30 to 40 to 50 and look back and
wonder what did we learn and that's
because at school we learn what to think
but not how to think and the ideal
education system has three elements an
ideal education is an education of the
head the heart and the Hand let me
explain what I mean please
please do the education of the head is
what we already receive academics
knowledge of math knowledge of English
science history geography these subjects
equip us with knowledge ideas thoughts
they educate our head they make us
understand things they improve our
memory when we learn them when we're
tested on them these are all valuable
skills for our future the challenges
that's currently all we get
I guess that's it yep the two that are
often missed out are the heart and the
hand and education in the heart is
understanding the values that lead to
long-term growth and long-term success
things like empathy kindness compassion
being able to have emotional
intelligence being able to be aware of
yourself and aware of others around you
knowing how to communicate effectively
knowing how to respect others beliefs
and boundaries knowing how to read in
between the lines of other people's
thoughts and emotions you good this
education in the heart would save us so
much time and so much energy and
potentially even so much money because
so much of it is wasted because we've
never been trained to understand
ourselves or understand others do you
understand yes and the final step is an
education in the hand being able to give
being able to teach being able to share
see we remember when we're engaged and
involved we learn more when we're
teaching we learn more when we're giving
when we're experimenting testing trying
things out that's when we accelerate our
growth and learning it's not just when
we're sitting back and waiting to hear
ideas and thoughts when we're taught how
to learn how to teach and how to share
we're able to grow we're able to enhance
we're able to start living far beyond
what we ever imagined because it allows
us to have that opportunity to test
ourselves in reality to test ourselves
with the real person and therefore the
two parts of Education that we missed
out on at school are the two we should
invest in for Life think about who are
the people that you want to be around
that can help you grow your education of
the heart values that you want to live
by mindsets that you see proving to be
successful in people's lives and think
about opportunities where you can make a
difference in the lives of others Gandhi
said that we find ourselves when we lose
ourselves in the service of others when
we use our skills to make a difference
in the life of other people we learn so
much more about those skills we learn so
much more about ourselves and we learn
so much more about the meaning and
fulfillment that comes from making a
difference don't blame school don't
blame your parents don't blame anything
that stopped us from getting a full
education all we have to do is get an
education in the head the heart and the
hand if at any point you feel like
you're not growing you're not moving
forward you're not feeling a positive
boost ask yourself which of these three
am I in need of because it's always
going to be one or two of those three
that you're missing rule number six help
others the truth is that the world we
live in where will always be uncertain
unpredictable
and
potentially include chaos
and the challenge is that in that time
it's very hard to find peace or find
calm or find joy
[Music]
and it's at those time
when we can use what we have
wherever in the world we are
to try to positively create peace
to try to serve others to try to
be there for others that is the only way
that we can experience Peace by being
Peace by creating Peace by sharing Peace
by sharing love
and
in terms of what we're looking for when
you're going through something difficult
you can't find happiness and you often
can't find peace immediately
but you can always find meaning and
service
and this is how we were trying to think
as monks that in times of uncertainty
don't look for certainty because you
won't find it look for service look for
where you can help how you can help
because when you start making a change
even in the smallest of ways when you
start supporting others and helping
others even in the tiniest of ways
you start to see that there's hope
there's possibility there's opportunity
so start wherever you are rule number
seven live life full of gratitude I was
around nine years old and I was visiting
India with my family we were stuck in
traffic and we were driving through a
slum area it was the first time I'd seen
homes built out of cardboard scrap metal
and Bricks all at the same time growing
up in London I'd never ever seen
anything like it before apart from on TV
or in the movies I saw some children on
the streets probably around the same age
as me but very different some of them
didn't have clothes they looked
undernourished and they probably didn't
have access to much water to tell by the
dryness on their lips and their skin I
noticed this one young girl who had a
head inside a trash can it looked like
she was scrambling for something when
she finally came out and looked at me
she smiled not knowing what to do I
smiled back she was obviously trying to
look for food and I could see her
scrambling and trying to reach in as far
as she could only then did I realize
that she only had arms she didn't even
have hands and she looked at me I could
tell she was hungry but by the time I
was just about to do something our car
took off and I could only see her now
and feel her disappointment that I
wasn't able to help at the time I didn't
have any food or money and before I
could ask my parents or the driver to
stop we were too far along on the
highway but I couldn't stop thinking
about her when we go back to the hotel I
got out of the car and it was lunch time
and even though I was really hungry I
couldn't eat because I couldn't get over
the fact that I couldn't have done
anything for that young girl that I just
saw even though I went to the buffet
with my parents it felt as if only me
and her had looked at each other in that
whole exchange and the whole city had
stopped I could remember exactly how she
looked as I was looking at the food when
we were there at the buffet I overheard
a couple arguing with the hotel stuff
listening into their conversation I
found out that the couple were really
upset at the hotel staff because of the
number of choices available in the
buffet I looked around there were so
many options they they were complaining
about there not being enough choice but
all I could see was Choice there were at
least 30 items just as starters
available to everyone there but it
wasn't enough for them now I get that
everyone has their own standards has
their own expectations in life and we're
allowed to have them and I know that
everyone is fighting their own battle
but that little girl she didn't even
have hands she was scraping with
whatever was left of her arms but many
years on from that event now I've
learned a lot one of the things is that
I can sit here and be angry at that
couple who was complaining or I could
actually do something about it it
reminded me of a quote by Gandhi he said
that I was sad because I didn't have any
shoes and then I saw a man with no feet
for me this event left a lasting
impression in my heart and two messages
that I want to share with you today the
first one is to remain grateful for
absolutely anything we have Robin
Roberts said it perfectly she said that
if we threw all our problems into our
pile we would rush to grab our own back
and when we start with gratitude and see
everything as fortune and Grace we're
able to receive much more deeply and
number two Let's help those who need it
let's not be mad that the world isn't
helping them let's see what we can do
compassion is key and empathy is
essential and that's one of the reasons
that I focus so much of my life in
trying to help those in need and it may
mean that you're in a space in your life
where you feel you can't currently help
anyone right now but I guarantee you
that there's just one person out on the
street today that you could impact that
you could change their experience at
least for a moment remember what Gandhi
said I was sad because I didn't have any
shoes and then I saw a man with no feet
it puts everything into perspective rule
number eight avoid conflicts now there
is no relationship in the world where
people don't argue if a couple says they
don't argue it can mean one of two
things either they're just getting to
know each other or they're lying are you
calling me a liar I'm calling you one if
you are one managing conflict is one of
the most important skills in any
relationship the one simple question
that improves any relationship is how
will I feel in one year about this
current conflict in my relationship
people feel more forgiving and interpret
their relationship in a more positive
light when looking at it from a future
perspective when couples and partners
argue about finances family jealousy or
attention or whatever it may be in those
situations we use our current feelings
as fuel for a heated argument
but with this simple shift we were
envisioning our relationships from the
future we're actually able to mitigate
conflicts and think of things with a
bigger perspective in picture everybody
calm down when we start thinking about
things through the future we use more
long-term thinking we start using our
reasoning strategies our more mature
intelligence rather than are currently
in most ocean-filled mind how many times
have you said something in the moment
that you regret later how many times
have you made an Impulse decision that
you later recognize wasn't the right one
a lot actually when we employ future
perspective thinking we get the ability
to rise above our current emotions and
start thinking from a point of
intelligence when we do this we blame
our partners less we take more
responsibility about what we can change
we're more forgiving and we're even more
able to focus on why the conflict
happened in the first place how many
times have you started an argument let
it continue for days and even forgotten
why it started I can't remember anything
that happened before two weeks ago next
time you're in a conflict and argument
or a debate with your partner ask
yourself this question how will I feel
in one year about this current conflict
in my relationship it will make a
difference and it will surely give you
perspective number nine use rejection to
grow just around two years ago I had
this idea I wanted to share wisdom at a
pace we wanted entertainment I wanted to
share wisdom in a way that it could
connect resonate and deeply evolve the
lives of people all over the world for
10 years before that I'd been working
with individuals groups coaching at
universities companies and all of these
opportunities but I really wanted to
serve and connect with everyone across
the world I wanted to make wisdom
accessible to anyone who had one of
these I have one of those so I was
excited I had the energy the enthusiasm
and I was pitching my idea to every
single company that was online now
remember this is before I ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
I was who's this guy I applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea I waited a day I waited two
days a way to do week I was rejected by
every single one of those companies
before interview none of them invited me
for a phone interview none of them
invited me for a video interview none of
them even connected with me in any
personal way that's rude I said to
myself it doesn't matter let's see what
else I can do to try and make my goal a
reality
so I tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance I got
one answer and one answer only they said
you're getting older now most of the
people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a masters and then
we'll take you seriously literally I was
getting rejected from every single
person I spoke to but inside of me I had
this desire had this calling I had this
Mission I had this Vision that I wanted
to share everything that I had learned
with people out there I I genuinely
tried every single possible method I
could to break into the media industry
to the point that the only thing that
was left that I could try was to start a
social media channel and of course you
know the rest the most incredible thing
is that it reminds me of a really
powerful thought from Thomas Edison he
once said when you believe you've
exhausted all options remember this you
haven't that thought stayed in my mind
the whole time what I learned from all
of this rejection from all of this
failure from all of these clear no's was
one really important thing and today I
want to give that as a gift to you me if
you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when I started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when I
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen that's when things started to
happen
this is nice it's when I decided to take
the responsibility for sharing what I
was passionate about with the world and
not waiting for someone external to
validate me or give me permission or
allow me to do that that's what made the
difference if you're feeling you've been
going through a lot of rejections ask
yourself this is your deeper passion and
calling making you want to move further
number two have you truly knocked on
every single door and number three are
you working hard on investing in your
expertise and passion so that you really
have something impactful to offer animal
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is connect with
purpose I think that people who found
their purpose are better Partners better
parents better professionals better
people
and so if everyone in the world was
deeply aligned and connected to their
purpose the world would be a beautiful
place and I think any pain we see in the
world comes from a disconnect with
purpose there's a beautiful thought from
Russell Barkley where he said that the
people who need the most love often ask
for it in the most unloving ways
so we confuse love
with power we confuse love with control
we confuse love with validation and
being liked and to me love comes from
living our purpose self-love and true
love with other people we all have
What's called the monk mind and the
monkey mind and as monks we were trained
to look at the parts of our minds that
we make mistakes that fail that do
things wrong is the monkey mind and
immediately when you think of your mind
like a monkey you just end up laughing
you're just like that's just the
silliest thing and so now when you start
seeing yourself do things that are out
of character or out of alignment or
things that you don't feel proud of
instead of judging yourself and
criticizing yourself you're approaching
it going well that's just a monkey mind
let me understand that is separate of me
that is not me that is a habit that I've
taken on that is a group of people that
have spent too much time with it's an
idea that I've absorbed if you can look
at these things as separate to who you
are you can now actually tackle them
versus when you think you are them it
just needs to guilt judgment
self-criticism and self-sabotage which
I'm sure a lot of us are privy to that
we go through this period where we're
like I can't believe I did that I
shouldn't have said that I wish I just
wish I didn't say that in that moment
and that doesn't change your behavior it
doesn't switch how you feel it just
creates more regret but when you go wait
a minute that's just the monkey mind
I've got that condition I've associated
with that type of environment and energy
let me approach it as something that is
separate of me creating that distance
and space for my challenges lets us
actually start solving them
Beth canopic understands eight years ago
she lost her 16 year old daughter lyanna
when suddenly and inexplicably a virus
lyanna contracted migrated to her heart
and could not be cured after a
tumultuous month in the hospital that's
vibrant joyful athletic daughter was
gone it's every parent's worst nightmare
and as you'd imagine a catapulted Beth
into what seemed like bottomless grief
and yet last year something incredible
happened Beth gathered 14 other mothers
in and around her Florida Town who had
all lost children for lunch she says
there wasn't a dry eye in the room only
the tears went from sadness they were
from Joy somehow each one of these
mothers some of whom had lost more than
one child were able to share positive
loving memories of their children along
with the beautiful ways their lives had
changed as a result of their profound
loss of course every one of these women
would rather have had their children
back but remarkably they were able to
take what had happened and allow
something powerful to grow from it as
one of my good friends Ray dalio says
pain plus reflection equals progress it
all starts in childhood we want to be
loved and accepted that's completely
normal but because of this need for love
and acceptance from just a few years of
age we begin to live according to what
others want for and from us we form
ideas about who and how we should be
based on what parts of us are behavior
and personality are welcome and praised
and which are not I like that about him
we also learn by imitating what we see
others doing as we grow older we shape
our likes and dislikes according to the
people we surround ourselves with for
example according to data from ad week
among 18 to 34 year olds 68 said that
their peers social media posts were at
least somewhat likely to influence them
to make a purchase I I got one for
myself see soon these attitudes and
behaviors we're imitating become
indistinguishable to us from who we
really are
in a pair of studies researchers
reviewed data from three different
seasons of the Premier League football
play and concluded that referee is
systematically favored home teams by
shortening close games where the home
team is ahead and lengthening close
games when the home team is behind the
reason pressure from the home crowd so
when it comes to making decisions we
change our own picture of reality to
avoid the discomfort that comes when we
go against what others think and that's
just strangers imagine the influence of
our friends our families and co-workers
and the effect they have on us yeah but
I'm your brother we're family what
finally does make us question our
thoughts and behavior is often that we
hit a wall maybe we wake up one day and
realize we're dreading going to work
maybe we're sitting with a group of
friends and suddenly we think what am I
doing here I don't fit in with these
people and then we end up asking even
more powerful questions like what do I
want to do with my life and who am I
really as billionaire investor Warren
Buffett once said chains of habit are
too light to be felt until they are too
heavy to be broken and maybe that's how
you feel like you're being weighed down
by this version of you that you've been
pretending to be or had to be because of
Life imagine your life was an empty jar
if you're filling that job with ideas
and beliefs that are not yours you're
living a life that isn't yours the first
type of filler we put in our lives that
blocks us from knowing ourselves is
other people's opinions so many of us
are in constant disconnect with
ourselves because we're always
validating or verifying others opinions
of us so
what do you think we let others ideas
and beliefs to find how we feel instead
of being Guided by our own values
following others opinions blindly can
quickly get us lost before I decided to
become a monk I was training to be an
investment banker working business when
I swapped to look at why I was chasing
this career that I wasn't really
interested in I realized I was following
my community's definition of success and
not my own this isn't me step back and
ask yourself why am I doing this is it
because it's what you truly want or is
it because it's Societies or someone
else's opinion of what you should do or
want if you want to know yourself and if
you want to experience meaning and
purpose this is the kind of stuff you
want to fill your life with your values
should come first when you isolate your
values you'll start to see more clearly
what's important to you you'll start to
get a sense of your passion and your
purpose and you'll be able to start to
see and understand what choices will
bring you closer to the life of your
dreams in the Manu Smithy which I talk
about and think like a monk it's a monk
book and in the verse it says when you
protect your purpose your purpose
protects you now I wanna I wanna unpack
that what I mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare Jewel
and a red gemstone
and imagine you were walking around with
the most expensive diamond or jewel in
the world how would you protect it you
want to just like you want to just wait
without you yeah you want to just wear
it on your chest like this like a baby
holding it yeah putting a pillow around
a blanket you'd be like yeah protect it
you'd protect it
and so your purpose is like that and
guess what people are going to tell you
every day
that that jewel is not worth anything
they're going to tell you that that
jewel is actually
valueless it doesn't have any impact on
your life they're going to try and take
away that value they're going to tell
you that there's another Jewel out there
that you need to have more value
and what ends up happening is you don't
I love the word look at the wording
protect your purpose you have to protect
it so what happens is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way Temptations
but they can all take you away from your
purpose distractions and to me I'm
repeating this for myself because I'm
like I just want to stick to what I was
born to do and I'm so grateful that I
get to do it I'm so happy I get to do it
and I want to keep protecting it I don't
want to get lost in the waves you know
you don't want to just get chucked in
the waves of the ocean and just get lost
and just not know where you're going so
for me when you protect your purpose
your purpose protects you so that's been
your biggest lesson that's my biggest
lesson why do you feel like your purpose
has been maybe distracted I don't think
it has but I'm saying it so it doesn't
like you're arriving yeah I'm reminding
myself like I'm preaching to myself
right now especially being in Hollywood
and the temptation of all these
opportunities out here totally and I
think for me it's a bigger lesson also
because it gives me more faith so I
always encourage and this is actually
actually this is why it's my biggest
lesson I encourage so many people that I
coach so many people I Mentor obviously
everyone in my community and audience
and everything to go and follow that go
and live that purpose and I see time and
time again that when I see people trying
to live their purpose they are protected
that things work when you're playing in
your Dharma and your purpose things work
things move you feel momentum they
happen and I'm not saying they happen
without effort but they happen they move
whereas when you're not you just
constantly feel like you're grinding up
against you know a war in a 2019
employee survey a PWC 71 of Millennials
said their money stress had gone up over
the past year it is stressing me out and
nearly half of all respondents said that
they spend three hours or more every
week thinking about or trying to sort
out their finances and money woes don't
just affect us individually 45 four
percent of young adults said that the
money is the number one stressor in
their relationship do I need to borrow
some money and check out these stats
according to Erin Lowry creator of the
broke Millennial Blog the average
Millennial graduated with 37 000 in
student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks Productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
Sue's Orman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
rough retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have hope you're seeing hang
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have sixty thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars and forty one cents I'm
gonna sit down and that's just with
basic compounding interest okay so
here's another big way we waste money
buying new now here's the thing I know
for lots of us I'll be honest myself
included how we look is important we
enjoy fashion but you can continue to
have your unique look and have favorite
Brands and still spend less money on
clothing here's a way to do that I have
another friend who's into designer
Brands but would never pay designer
prices her secret is to shop at
consignment stores and now that there
are lots of these stores online there
are tons of items to choose from and you
can even shop by your favorite Brands
the other month I complimented my friend
on a sweater and she told me she got it
for 65 less than the original price and
it came brand new with the tag still
attached plus shopping Consignment also
benefits the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff Beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to for
example if your iPhone breaks you can
actually buy a refurbished one directly
from Apple for way less money and they
come with a warranty and don't get me
started on cars here's another quiz when
you drive a new car off the lot it
literally immediately loses a certain
percentage of its value what percentage
is it a five percent
B 10 or C 30 the answer is B according
to Carfax the second you drive a new car
off the lot it loses at least 10 percent
in value over the first year it loses
about 20 of its value that means if you
spend thirty thousand dollars on a brand
new car within a year it's worth only
twenty four thousand dollars and the
value just keeps going down instead of
needing everything brand new look at
what you can buy used or borrow from
someone you know and that's another way
we waste money we buy things immediately
we think of it we get all excited we go
online and buy it it's like when the
Apple watch first came out and I went
out and bought one I was so stoked but
no offense to the product I discovered
pretty quickly just in time to give it
back that I didn't actually need it I
ended up returning it take it back
instead of impulse buying batch your
purchases if you say oh I need to buy
that whatever it may be and then go to
Amazon and buy it and then later in the
day I wanted to get some of that other
thing I loved and then going to Amazon
or another store to buy that what
happens when you get your card statement
it all adds up and you're like whoa how
did I spend that much money I don't
remember any of that and that's because
fifteen dollars here and ten dollars
there doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment but you
don't see the money you don't feel it
you don't actually have that experience
of giving it away or holding on to it
instead when you think of something you
need and I'm putting need in quotes
because it might not be a real need but
to want put it in your cart and leave it
there or write it down on a list don't
buy it right away then at some specified
time like the end of the week look at
your list or your cards and choose what
it is you really need that will give you
a better idea of what you're actually
spending and what you actually need
versus what you want people who are
happy passionate and successful are
everywhere right can't we just turn to
them to see what they did to get there
not quite a few years ago Gallup
conducted an international poll that
included questions about workplace
happiness and engagement how many people
said they felt engaged at work was it a
65 B 35 or C 15 if you guessed a you're
way off the answer is C only 15 of
people worldwide said they felt engaged
at work that means that 85 of people
around the world don't find meaning and
purpose in what they do considering that
according to writer Gemma Curtis we
spend 13 years and two months of our
lives at work that's a lot of time being
upset but when we look around we see a
different story right social media posts
show people pursuing their dreams and
living their best lives and news and
interviews showcase entrepreneurs
stumbling on that great idea creating a
company and selling it all before age 25
yet as we just saw the statistics don't
bear this out in Japan a whopping 94 of
survey respondents said that they're not
engaged at work it's a bit better in the
US but not much only 30 percent of
workers say they're happier with their
work this is colliding with what Gallup
says is an increased focus on the value
of work among Millennials they want a
job and a career that's dream worthy
keep dreaming was worth a shot so in a
world that's so unhappy be at work how
do we make that dream come true there's
a single powerful secret I'm going to
share that will help you sort it all out
there's a Zen story about two monks
standing in the garden of the monastery
watching some prayer Flags waving in the
distance one monk comments the wind is
moving the other monk shakes his head no
he says it's the flags that are moving a
senior monk walks by and the two monks
ask his opinion he said you are both
wrong it is your mind that is moving
that's the powerful secret that in life
it's actually less about what you
experience and more about how you
experience it that's important the truth
is actually less about what job you have
and more about how you do it that shapes
the quality of your life that actually
makes a lot of sense Katrina Lake didn't
know what to do after college so she
decided to work at a consulting firm it
was there that she became curious about
what would happen if you technology with
clothing retail her initial idea flocked
but she kept exploring going on to work
for a venture capital firm then on to
business school finally Lake had her big
idea she would marry personal shopping
with online clothes buying she started
shopping for her friends and keeping
meticulous data about what they liked
and didn't and why business plan and
spreadsheets in hand she began to search
for funding and was turned down by more
than 50 different Venture capitalists
that didn't stop her though periodically
she would get just enough money to keep
going and building her idea in 2017 Lake
became the youngest woman in history to
take a company public and in 2020 Stitch
fix was valued at 3.37 billion dollars
Lake did an interview with the podcast
skimmed from the couch and was asked the
worst piece of advice she'd ever gotten
what was it follow your dreams Lake says
no notion that your job should be your
dream job is misleading so many parts of
this job have not been a dream she said
whether it was struggling to raise money
cramming to get Stitch fix boxes out the
door on time or being the one who had to
go out and buy a new printer when theirs
broke down here's the thing you can be a
strong broker who makes millions of
dollars but is miserable or you can be a
grocery clerk who changes others lives
simply with your kindness and caring the
difference lies in how you approach life
and that difference comes from your
motivation social scientist Tim Casa
studies values and goals including two
types of motivation extrinsic such as
for money image or status and intrinsic
such as for personal growth close
relationships and making the world a
better place he and his colleagues have
consistently found that people who place
a high value on extrinsic versus
intrinsic goals are less happy and for
lower levels of satisfaction with Life
along with higher levels of anxiety and
depression and external rewards can even
decrease the internal motivation you
already have researchers took a group of
kids at a nursery school who had a
natural love of drawing in one group the
children were just left to draw in
another they were told they could earn a
good player award which included a
ribbon and a certificate if they drew a
picture two weeks later the same kids
were offered the opportunity to draw
pictures those who are allowed to just
draw showed the same high level of
interest in drawing the second time
around but those who were told they
could earn a reward by drawing a picture
the first time around what half is
likely to want to draw another picture
what's in it for me the external reward
actually made them less motivated to
draw when we do things out of intrinsic
motivation we're more likely to find
meaning and purpose in our lives lives
and our work for Katrina Lake it was her
love of data along with wanting to
answer the question what could the
future of retail look like here are
three ways to connect with your
intrinsic motivation first live for who
you want to become create a vision of
who you want to be in five years in that
vision of yourself list out five ways
you're feeling about your life and your
work and your relationships are you
excited joyful satisfied fulfilled
driven confident be as specific as
possible now for the next week every
time you make a choice ask yourself if
that choice will bring you closer to or
take you further away from that vision
of yourself in five years do you want to
play a video game or read a book do you
want to watch a movie or have a
conversation do you want to take a class
or waste time scrolling on social media
hey there's nothing wrong with any of
those things I said I love them all but
we need the right ratio we need to make
sure that more of our steps are leading
us towards who we want to be than away
it's simple math tip number two is
discover where you can connect something
you're already doing or have a natural
strength or inclination for to something
you're passionate about that connection
Point your passion doesn't have to pay
you but if your current job can pay your
passion that might just be as good and a
good start check this out when computer
science Professor Louis Von on set out
to create new lingo he had one
motivation to make learning free as a
kid growing up in poverty he saw so many
kids who didn't have access to Quality
education so he and Upon A Creative
Duolingo a language learning app that's
now used by more than 14 million people
worldwide and while the company has
become tremendously profitable Anne's
motivation was never about making money
it was about giving back that's major
intrinsic motivation connecting your
passion with a larger purpose one of my
greatest gloves and one of the things
that motivates me is learning and that's
the third tip learning to love learning
and no matter what you do in life you
cannot fail if you look at every
situation and ask yourself what can I
learn here you're going to experience
two things you get to feel curiosity or
and wonder three things that research
shows contribute to feeling satisfaction
and meaning in your life and second if
you're always focused on learning you
will never be disappointed because even
when something doesn't go the way you'd
hoped or planned you can learn from it
as Katrina Lake says I think a lot of
people find themselves unhappy in their
jobs because it's not their dream but I
think at the end of the day if you're
learning and if you're working with
great people that's going to be a
rewarding experience and that's how you
too can have a rewarding fulfilling
purposeful life and career when you're
going on a long car trip you take your
car to the map attic First Rate to get
things recalibrated realigned and ready
to go that's our second M how we're
going to recalibrate for our new journey
is to adjust our self-awareness
neuroscientist David Eagleman says that
as far as our brains are concerned as
adults we are more like our peers than
our childhood selves yet when we think
about who we are we mostly base our
ideas on our younger self so tune up
your self-awareness you're going to go
on a data Gathering Expedition among
those who know you best Simon sinek the
author of start with Y has a great
exercise for this when people say I
don't know what I'm good at or I don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right there's a saying that you
can't read the label from inside the job
so you're going to ask people outside
your jar to help you out can you help me
you're going to ask three to five five
people who know you well it may be
personal professional friends to
describe for you what makes you special
ask them Simon recommends why are you
friends with me why did you pick me as
your partner or what makes me stand out
as an employee what do you really like
about me as your parent now beware most
people will answer first with something
general you're smart you're funny you're
a good listener that's that's not deep
enough anything else ask for more for
example lots of people are funny why are
you friends with me instead of someone
else who's funny or lots of employees
are dedicated can you give me more
detail like a specific incident or
example that really showed you that tell
me more then you'll start getting the
truly helpful data and information such
as I love the way you use humor to make
other people feel welcome and
comfortable or you have this ability to
take our discussions Deeper by bringing
in insights from lots of other fields
that's very nice of you to say you start
to see yourself through others eyes and
get an understanding of what's working
what your strengths are that you can go
deeper on and maximize and What Makes
You uniquely you here's an awesome idea
convene a feel-good Roundtable in person
or over Zoom with a few good friends or
family members or even do this with
co-workers where you go around and tell
each other some of your greatest
strengths in detail then you're
spreading the love and the joy and the
support as well and it doesn't feel as
awkward as just asking it for yourself
please don't make this awkward for me
okay so what else do we need to start a
journey strong we need some idea of
where we're going right a map that's our
third end you just learned about all
these great things you've got going for
you but no doubt you also have an area
of 2 or 12 that's me where you'd like to
grow so we're going to create a map of
how to get there and one way you can do
that is to pick a mentor someone who
embodies that quality tea or those
qualities you're looking to grow this
year one of my greatest mentors is
Martin Luther King Jr specifically the
way he inspired people for a meaningful
cause and connected people to his
powerful words maybe if you want to
become better at relating to others your
Mentor is Oprah Winfrey maybe if you
want to be more strategic and thoughtful
when it comes to business it's your
father or mother that was the case for
John Mackey the founder of Whole Foods
his father was his business Mentor for
years maybe if you want to cultivate
Innovation or persistence your Mentor is
someone like Sir James Dyson or Richard
Branson next figure out basic simple
ways to connect with your Mentor
regularly if it's not someone you can
connect with in real life you can read
their work watch their videos listen to
a podcast read about their lives tape an
inspiring fact about them or quote from
them above your desk or put it into your
wallet remember it's not that you want
to mimic your Mentor you want to be
yourself and combine those strands
developing with those great strengths
you already have in place but if you
look at some of the geography your
Mentor has traveled it can help provide
you with your own map for developing
those strengths the first thing is that
purpose is like an adult right finding
your purpose is like an adult in terms
of growth passion is like a teenager but
before you become a teenager what are
you you're a child child is like the
interest and before you're a child
you're a baby that's curiosity
so at the baby stage of passion what you
first need is curiosity that Curiosity
turns into an interest that interest
turns into a passion that passion turns
into a purpose for so many of us we get
stuck trying to be like well what's my
passion it's like saying well I should
be a teenager before I'm even a baby
let's first learn to crawl before we
learn to walk or run or fly so when we
start there we ask yourself what am I
curious about what could I watch
documentaries about forever what could I
get excited about learning forever what
is it that I keep getting up to do even
if I fail what is it that I get
motivated to learn about or hear about
or read about or watch about even when I
don't know so much about it what are you
naturally curious about and drawn
towards in your life that is the
birthplace of your passion it doesn't
have to be a passion just yet it just
needs to be a curiosity or an interest
according to writer Gemma Curtis each of
us has on average 28 000 835 days in our
lives of that time we spend 33 years in
bed seven of them trying to fall asleep
one year and four months exercising
unless you're my wife from guessing will
spend something like five years
exercising she loves it we spend 11
years and four months on non-work screen
time and eight years and four months of
that is spent watching TV with the rest
on social media in fact we spend six
times longer watching TV and two times
longer on social media than exercising
yet experts say that even just 10
minutes of exercise a day would increase
the overall quality of our sleep 10
minutes see how it's all interconnected
we'll also spend about three years on
vacation that might sound like a lot but
compare that to the 13 years and two
months will spend at work unless you're
Elon Musk who says he spent 15 years
working 100 hours or more a week he's
been known to sleep under his desk
ladies most of you will spend about 136
days getting ready guys it's about 46
days for you unless you're me we spent
four years and six months eating 66 of
workers say they eat meals at their
desks we spend 235 days waiting in line
after all of that it's no wonder that we
spend just one year and three days of
our life socializing but here's some
good news we spend about 115 Days of Our
Lives laughing it's pretty shocking
right who knew we were spending so much
time on things we probably don't really
care about and so little on the things
we do here's the thing and I say this in
my book think like a monk no matter what
you think your values are your actions
tell the real story sure there are
things we have to do like go to work but
when we have free time we dedicate that
time to what we value you may say and
even believe that you value time with
your partner or your kids most of all
but when you have spare time you're more
often scrolling on your phone or with
your friends there's a well-known saying
by Ben Franklin and it's worth
remembering it goes when you take care
of the minutes the hours will take care
of themselves when we don't spend our
time on what we value mostly that's not
on purpose it's because we're simply not
paying attention part of that is because
for a lot of us by the time we have
spare time we're wiped out and it's just
hard to get motivated to change gears I
need my sleep the other reason we waste
time is we discount the value of our
minutes you're probably familiar with
the dreaded time Gap that's what I call
the mysterious black hole where our
missing time goes you know when you're
at work and you sit down to do something
but then a headline pops up on your news
alerts and you click on it and the next
you look at the clock it's 45 minutes
later and you don't know where the time
went or when you get home and you're
about to change your clothes to get some
exercise but first you just want to
forward this hilarious meme to a friend
and then all of a sudden 90 minutes have
gone by and you'll see still sitting on
your couch I must have lost track of
time we lose time because we treat our
minutes Like Dimes a dime isn't worth
much to most right it's just like 10
cents if we were walking down the street
and saw a dime most of us wouldn't even
stop to pick it up according to data
from provision living the average
American spends 324 minutes on their
phone every day if you measure that in
dimes over a single day you'd have
enough money to pay for a drop in yoga
or Meditation Plus over seven days you'd
have enough to pay for organic groceries
for a week for two people over a month
you could take a long weekend at a
deluxe Airbnb but let's say you didn't
spend those dimes but instead put them
in a basic savings account by the end of
the year you'd have 11
826 but forget dimes in actual minutes
if you spend just an hour Less on your
mobile phone per day you'd have an extra
21 900 minutes per year that's a lot of
time saved and a lot more time to do the
things that support you your health of
your well-being along with the other
things and people you value have you
ever had that vacation that you've been
getting ready for that you've been so
psyched about and by the time you're
ready
getting ready to leave what's happening
stress right you're running around like
what do I pack did we put out a note for
the dog sitter where's our Uber all
right here I know my wife and I can have
our moments when we're both trying to
tie things up and get ready for some
time off and it's ridiculous right that
that's how we're starting out as we set
out on our journey this new year let's
spend some time and energy deliberately
setting our mindset we're going to do it
with gratitude and here's how writer
Marcel proust once said let us be
grateful for the people who make us
happy they are the Charming gardeners
who make our souls Blossom Kelly
McGonagall is a professor and researcher
at Stanford University and her work
centers on this idea that's stress
neither good nor bad it's our reaction
to it that matters she says that one of
the most effective positive ways we can
deal with stress is to practice
gratitude but not just any kind of
gratitude specifically she says that
it's the gratitude that focuses on
others and their impact on our lives
that's most effective Dr McGonagall says
that stress is designed to motivate us
to get us to do something in the case of
the stress of loneliness for example
it's designed to move us to connect and
when we can feel gratitude for things
others have done for us it helps us feel
more hopeful more willing to seek help
and support and to offer help and
support to others sounds like an amazing
mindset to start out with right yeah it
does so every day for one week each
morning when you get up spend three to
five minutes diving deep into one
beautiful or meaningful thing someone
has done for you in your life be
specific you're grateful to your mom for
helping you with your homework or you're
grateful for your best friend and fifth
grade for that time he stood up to
someone who is bullying you and of
course it can be something in recent
memory too be sure to remember the
sights sounds and smells and what was
said so you can really reinforce that
memory in your body and in your brain
it's one of the biggest and most common
things that wears us out and weighs us
down every single day starting from the
time we wake up negativity doesn't it
often feel like everywhere you look most
of the headlines and social media posts
even messages from your friends and
family are negative why does it seem
like no matter where we turn negativity
is just coming at us from every
direction I'm not about that negativity
when it comes to negativity research
tells us some interesting things about
human behavior scientists from McGill
University set up a study that
participants were told was about
observing their eye tracking patterns
while they read news from a web page
really the scientists just wanted to see
which articles the participants picked
and overwhelmingly was negative articles
but why another study reported in adweek
showed that on average negative
headlines outperform positive Headlines
by 63 and data from Pew reset says that
two-thirds of Americans say they feel
worn out by the sheer amount of news
that's out there just the quantity is
tiring and negative it's way too much
it's just too much research has also
estimated that up to 80 of our thoughts
every day are negative so I'm going to
give you three ways to lighten your
negativity load so you can start feeling
more energized and positively engaged
scientists have concluded that our over
consumption of negativity is due at
least in part to something called
negativity bias we're wired to detect
threats so we give more of our attention
to things that are negative so let's say
you're out on a hike in a gorgeous
location there might be 99 beautiful
things to take in about your
surroundings the birds the trees the
cascading waterfall but the second you
hear little Russell in the bushes all of
your attention will go to that one sound
because your brain is worried it can be
a threat did you hear that there's also
research that sheds some light on what
encourages negativity in our Social
Circles according to neuroscientists
certain receptors for dopamine the
reward chemical actually become
unavailable when we don't give a
socially desirable response to others if
your friends say let's go to the ABC
grill for lunch you're more likely to
get that feel-good dopamine hit if you
say sounds great even if that's not what
you want to eat our brains want us to
fit in if you've ever participated in
Gossip or other negative behavior and
then wondered why you did that this
helps to explain it oh I feel better
about myself the negativity odds may
feel like they're stacked against us but
we really can decrease the negativity in
our lives and we do it through small
simple choices made consistently going
along with your friends even though you
disagree is like someone offering you a
sugary candy bar it's hard to resist and
tastes great in the moment but later you
feel the weight of that choice when
you're burned out tired potentially
depressed I made a mistake that food
analogy can be helpful when looking at
the negativity in our lives like junk
food junk thoughts and junk Behavior are
weighing us down if I'm giving myself a
steady diet of refined sugar and
processed food if that's what I'm
ingesting I'm going to be tired and
cranky I'm awake I'm awake
if I eat lots of fresh produce if I'm
consuming things that are more positive
I'm going to feel energized I'll feel
more motivated my mood will be better
and my thoughts will be clearer and that
makes it easier to make healthy
decisions it's self-perpetuating have
you ever found it when you're tired you
eat worse when you eat worse you're more
tired if our daily diet is made up of
judgment and anger we're going to feel
terrible we won't be as creative and we
won't feel inspired studies even show we
won't be as physically healthy because
people who are mostly negative get sick
more often Harvard did a research study
on 3 000 leaders managers individuals
working inside organizations and they
looked at the top performing ones and
they wondered and asked what was the
number one skill they had
and it came down to this one word
associating the ability
to connect dots where people usually see
differences
the ability to find parallels and
similarities and synergies where other
people only see divide and disconnection
we live in these Echo Chambers inside
our organizations we get lost around the
same group of three to four people we
get lost in the same mini groups of
people and we don't expand our minds
beyond that people with broader networks
people who had people in their lives
that were very different from the other
people were actually able to provide
more creative more productive more
effective ideas and Solutions in the
company because they were able to look
at things from multiple angles different
perspectives how can we start to
recognize
that when we win and someone else wins
when we win together when we're able to
help and serve and support each other
together
that so much more can happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Brendan burchard
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if you wrote down
your three top priorities for the day do
those first before you do your social
media before you reply to everyone's DMS
inbox voice message texts I have so many
people they spend all day